>>> I THK S FAVORITE COLOR
PURPL
I'M MICHAEL SMCOELPHIA.
EREASTER BOUGHT MY SECONTESLA.I,
CON ECS
UNTIL CENTI HAVEN'
PO INSTEADN MUSK IN
ADMIRED HIFONOYT U THE SUBJECT
BID FOR TWITR IS AUT.E -- AE YO
SOMETHING YOU DON'T LIKE
E CASEE EC
D IT'S DAMN ANONNOYING SAYS
SOMELIKE.
THAT IS SOMETHING OF HEALTHY
FUNCTIONING FREE SPEECH
SITUATION.
ISEST INTE
TREPIDATION ONEWS, HE WAS PORT
BUTHE LLMUSK'S
SITHEMBRACEXPRESSION, ATS
GROWINATEIR S?SO
ELK IS CHALLENGING             .
AT
POST" WHO SAIDQUOTE, I AM
I E COMPETIN BFILLING.TWITTEO BE
ARTISANS HEAR THEID OUTLET
MUSK OR SIT THEY'R
GOING TO FALL ININIT TO
MUE HIS POLITI?1, T HRIPOLITICA
AND SOCIALLY LIKE A LOT OF THE
>> THEN IN J 2018,TW
COVAREGIST
INNDOLITICALLY
TE.
. IE EXEM M T OUT
TION, D CNBC
>> IEEA BIER THAT
DOESN'T SEEM THE SOR
CHARACTETHE IT
>> IHERU
ACTUALLY  HE DECLARED IN A
NS
THE MOST
TIVET ENO GOOD W
ACALSING HARM.
TRUEIA.
HE'S ALSNOGUY DONATING O
HEF $1
MILLION TO POLITICS, PARTI APACL
23 TINTON AN
AVM IN BUSARCO
RU01Y GR.N McCARTHY I2800JO
THTAL DONATIONS
AND REPUBLICAR
JU A>> WHO DO TH BRING T
THY
>>EL
MODERATE, YOU F
, THEN WOULD
I CAN MOST PEOPLY WANT
A PRESIDENT WHO IS J CO.
YOU NOT TOGH
>> THE GUYCOMPLE
E MIDDLE, ASOF OBJECT  THEUSKT R
FFING ONARST M RS REJECENTTOE .
JUES KINGDOM
OWN RER
WHAT V FREEDOM OF SPPROVEWED FO
E FOR TESL OPEL WHITE,  S DEE, E
ADD THFOR I WANTKNOW WHAT YO TO
YOU WANT ELON MUSK TO TAKER IT
IN KARHEWRITTEN THIS COLUM
"TIM,"N MUSK KNOWS EXACTLY
I KNOW IUN WITCRTOCTLY IS HE?
OTWITTER.S IT'SNG THE
DIREN. CEN
WHERE IT WAS DURING IPO  HIDTH E
HE LIKES TO   AND JUST KE
THEM.
MES TW PEOPLE.S,CESSARILCOOL HE
OFF
I DOF .
KE SOME OFT.INTER.
TH WNG.
>>E NOTES USEDTTER
WHEN IHELU.INKING OF THOSE
YOU KNOW WHAT I'OU WE CA, KES "
D  CLOCK, I
KNOW.
JO LIKES TDOAT
O OV L ALL  MEMES TBE V AGAIN H,
E AN 11-YEAR-OLD
ISEDULARLYS UP PICTURES
OF THE HE'DIR NGD
AS YS X FIGURE.HAMP, TO BSF
COMING B 2024,  TEDR
EAMETHING
>>
MUSK,  HE'S SFP'S SUPPORTERSOR
HE'SITACDO'D
GOOF PEOPLGHPENEAI'T THINK IT'
IDEA, BUT TWITTER A PMPAN
.Y HARD
RUFOR PRESIDENT AND   P
RYD. BPORARY S OR TIME-OUTS.
M